PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Welcome to "Get
Cooking in Cloud," where
we share the best recipes
to apply in your Cloud kitchen.
I am Priyanka.
And in this episode, we'll talk
about Warm Disaster Recovery
pattern for applications that
are deployed on Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Main Street Art currently
runs their web application
on Compute Engine.
It's mostly a static website.
So in the unlikely event that
their site is not available,
they can use a failover to
static website on Google Cloud
Storage.
Main Street Art is
very cost-conscious,
so they have gone for
a zonal setup, which
won't cause them problems if
the zone becomes temporarily
unavailable.
So this recipe provides them
with a cost-effective way
to recover.
Their primary application
runs on Google Compute Engine.
These instances are grouped
into managed instance groups.
And the instance groups serve as
backend services for HTTPS load
balancer.
The HTTP load balancer
directs incoming traffic
to the instances according
to the load balancer
configuration, the configuration
of each instance group,
and the health of each instance.
This provides HA, but for
the belt and braces approach,
this recipe is worth discussing.
Here's how Main Street
Art would set it up.
They would have to
create a VPC network
and then create a custom
image that's configured
with the application service.
Use that image to create
an instance template.
Using this instance
template, configure
a managed instance group
with health checks and load
balancing.
Then create a Cloud
Storage-based static website.
Check out earlier
episodes to cook it up.
Then finally,
configure the Cloud
DNS to point to the
primary application,
and the standby static
site sits dormant.
Now, what happens in case the
Compute Engine application
goes down?
Well, Main Street
Art would just have
to configure Cloud DNS to
point to the static site.
And when Compute Engine is back
up and running again and can
support production
workloads, Main Street Art
can reverse the recovery steps.
They will just have to configure
Cloud DNS to point to the load
balancer that fronts
the instances.
Well, there you have it.
If your web application
already runs on Google Cloud
and you are on this
very specific budget
to meet those RTO
and RPO values, then
you can use the Warm
DR pattern and failover
to a static website on
Google Cloud Storage.
That's all for today on
"Get Cooking in Cloud."
Here's hoping you're whipping
up your own DR strategy.
Join us next time where
we will share the recipe
to implement a Hot Disaster
Recovery and High Availability
for an application on GCP.
If you would like to
see more such content,
don't forget to like and
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]